je vois beaucoup de gens sur les réseaux
qui me disent euh à quoi sert Benjamin
et ben on va vous le dire non mais
aujourd'hui j'ai décidé de crever la psy
il est extrêmement important l'émission
je vous le dis ça n'est pas parce qu'une
personne ne parle pas
qu'elle ne compte pas
regardez les mimes
le mille morceaux fait toute une
carrière sans parler
lui il est indispensable à l'émission
C'est notre Nivea crème de l'émission
je vais citer bien sûr d'autres marques
bien entendu Garancia merci merci à vous
merci merci les spécialistes de la
beauté la prairie déjà première question
si vous deviez évaluer votre année sur
une échelle de 1 à 10
ça va vous surprendre je mettrais 10
je vais vous dire pourquoi
je vais vous expliquer pourquoi on a
entretien individuel Merci
si je vous compare vous êtes un
capitaine de vaisseau exceptionnel alors
si tu vas me sucer
vous êtes un capitaine de vaisseau
exceptionnel et le vaisseau c'est un
petit peu l'équipe et ce n'est pas quand
la mer est plate ce n'est pas quand il
n'y a pas de vent c'est pas quand il y a
pas de tempête qu'on reconnaît les bons
éléments c'est quand il y a de la
tempête du vent le feu les femmes
qui faut tenir la balle il faut tenir la
barre et qu'il faut être là vous avez
tenu quel barbe
la vôtre
c'est une barre de chocolat et je suis
l'homme sur qui on peut compter quand
mais ça secoue comment ça secoue mais je
serai toujours là à vos côtés
alors les arguments c'est pas mon fort
[Rires]
on peut pas on peut pas demander
la présence alors mon point fort déjà
c'est c'est qui je suis ce que je suis
intrinsèquement ce que je renvoie en
fait c'est moi c'est la légende que j'ai
été et que je suis donc c'est ça donc on
paye la légende et ben oui ça vous casse
ça coûte cher les gens écoutez une
vieille bagnole ça coûte plus cher
qu'une neuve bah oui alors si on doit
payer une légende prenons directement
quelqu'un de mort parce que parce que
quand même même si je ne parle pas je
bouge encore
oui je peux encore m'exprimer donc
quelque part quand on s'offre une
légende un homme qui va célébrer bientôt
30 ans de carrière et oui 30 parce que
ça ça compte dans les grands comme ça
alors
ça fait combien d'années vous êtes là ça
fait 8 ans bah comptez 22 ça fait 8 ans
et j'entends j'entends il parle pas mais
c'est pas dans la qualité de la parole
qui parfois ne vaut rien le silence est
d'or la parole est d'argent c'est le
théâtre
mais je vais vous demande pas je vous
demande pas si vous voulez une
augmentation bien sûr que oui
alors bien évidemment tu regardes je
vais faire quelque chose que je ne fais
jamais le fait jamais fait diminuer une
réduction
[Musique]
j'ai déjà réduit ma poitrine alors quels
sont vos souhaits pour la saison
prochaine si on a une pour vous alors ça
je ne sais pas c'est à vous de décider
chef non mais c'est pas non mais non
mais si vous pas me déjà dites-moi ce
qu'il en est l'année prochaine et je
verrai ce que je peux éventuellement
amener de plus qu'est-ce que mon talent
pourrait amener à la quand je vous
écoute est-ce que vous avez prévu de
prendre un rendez-vous avec un
orthophoniste
les prochains travaux de l'année
prochaine la gérer du ma peau ma
poitrine je vais donc
l'année prochaine j'ai réfléchi est-ce
que vous aimeriez en plus en moins alors
en moins rien non vraiment on voit
vraiment vraiment rien en plus il faut
toujours un peu plus est-ce que vous
sentez en position de force alors
écoutez oui honnêtement
mais vous savez pourquoi
parce que je suis face je suis face à
l'animateur que je suis et là je peux
m'exprimer et vous aimeriez qu'on fasse
une émission que tous les deux voilà
donc vous voulez revenir
en fait quand je suis là j'entends pas
je vois pas parce qu'ils s'arrête de
mauvaise place c'est pas mais je vous ai
déjà mis là c'était pas non non
il faut que il faut que je me dort
et moi on verra donc j'ai réfléchi
l'année prochaine j'ai admiré
l'animateur que vous êtes le grand
animateur et je le dis tous les jours
tous les jours je ne fais que ça non
mais attendez je vais écouter je veux
parler je parle merde donc il y a cet
homme là qui joue au paddle et je me
disais il y a un objectif c'est le même
c'est le même alors il faut arriver dans
le top 100 et pour ça il faut vraiment
s'entraîner régulièrement il faut
il faut vraiment il faut il faut y aller
il faut il faut y croire il faut y aller
donc donc je vous conseille un conseil
écoutez un pro comme moi 30 ans de télé
écouter un peu s'il vous plaît bon je
pense qu'il est je pense qu'il est
impératif Cyril Hanouna de vous reposer
le vendredi alors je vais te dire mais
oui la chaîne est leader TNT oui et ben
oui mais le vendredi est extrêmement
important oui mais c'est pas grave donc
tu feras des vendredis mais pas sur la
chaîne ici
[Applaudissements]
mais bon si vous le dites Benjamin pour
dire ce que je pense de lui voilà on a
compris quand même globalement
il est c'est vraiment on est toujours
tous contents très très content de le
voir à chaque fois qu'il vient et je me
disais Benjamin c'est vrai que c'est
quelqu'un c'est on adore quand il est là
dans les dans les loges maquillage
est-ce que votre place n'est pas là
tu le rends compte dans les
couloirs
c'est génial donc non non c'est un très
bon camarade et franchement il mérite
j'ai dit il mérite
un avertissement
[Applaudissements]
oui mais il peut pas le faire voilà
essayez les encouragements
[Applaudissements]
merci merci beaucoup merci beaucoup
merci
[Applaudissements]